What if everything you've been told
about building a good life is wrong?
Harvard researchers tracked the same
people for 85 years from their teenage
years until they passed away. They
measured everything. Brain scans, blood
pressure, career success, wealth
accumulation. After 85 years, one
finding dominated all others. The single
strongest predictor of a healthy, happy,
long life was the quality of a person's
relationships.
Not career success, not intelligence,
not money. Here's what hit hardest. The
loneliest participants didn't look
lonely, they looked busy. Packed
calendars, impressive achievements. But
here's the warning. Your relationship
satisfaction at age 50 predicts your
health at age 80. Better than your
cholesterol levels do. When they asked
participants in their 80s what they
regret, nobody said they wished they'd
worked more. The universal regret,
relationships. The study took 85 years
to figure this out. You don't have to.